>> DE RIJK: So, yeah, I'm going to give a
bit of a talk about our development practices,
things we do inside this project. Remember,
this is not me telling you how we're--what
we're doing is right. It's kind of me telling
us what we're doing now and we're open for
discussions on this topic. That's also why
this talk is relatively short. Please try
to keep the discussions after I'm done. If
you have any questions, please feel free to
ask them during the presentation. So, yeah,
I'm going to walk you through our principles
regarding, basically, from ID to patch. So
I'm going to talk a bit about Design docs.
How to--I'm going to give you a quick tutorial
on how to import this project into Eclipse
since that's something that Joseph mentioned
this morning. I'm going to talk about Code
style, why your commit should be small, our
code reviews, the fact that we have continuous
build and test up and running and how to deal
with third party dependencies inside our project.
So, yeah, let's get started. So if you have
a--if we want to make large changes to our
code base, we really--we proud ourselves on
the fact that we actually write Design docs
for these things because it's pretty important
because we want to communicate to you guys
also internally what we've been doing is that
what and how we're going to change. And that
way, we can agree on our approach before we
write to much code which, well, would basically
be lost time if we had to change some stuff.
And also, you should talk and not worry about
the fact that the doc might become out of
date after something's implemented because
the way this project works is basically kind
of like extreme programming; it's continuously
changing. So you shouldn't worry about that
too much. But it's important that you discuss
big changes with the rest of the people so
that they know what you are doing. And things
to include in Design doc is, of course, the
objective, what do you want to reach a requirements,
what does it need to do, what does it need
to uphold. You need to include the design.
And a good other thing to do is that--then
to talk also a bit about the alternatives
you have considered and why those alternatives
did not make it to be the actual design. That
way, you can give a better image, a better
overview of what you want, what you thought
about during your process of making this design
upfront. So, now, I'm going to switch over
to show you quickly how to import this project
into Eclipse. On the Google Code site, you
can grab this handy-dandy comment you can
run when you have a mercurian staff installed.
Let me quickly go out here. Just paste it
in. You can change the map name if you want
to, you fold them in and then kind of check
out. The meantime, Eclipse is our personal
preferred ID. Of course, you can use anything
you want, but we actively have a project file
and code style file for Eclipse. So, if you--if
you use it, you're in good hands with us.
While that's checking out, you should make
sure that you have Java 1.6 or, well, Java
6 installed. So, there were some problems
with projects not compiling for some people
where their compliance was not set to the
right level. I will quickly show you where
you can do that as soon as the check out is
finished. There we go. So, yeah, basically,
all you have to do in Eclipse is do a new
Java project. You give it a name, like Google
Wave demo or whatever. You don't use default
location. You browse to the folder you checked
out. You'll see a bit of gadget work there.
You tell Eclipse to use that project--to use
that folder. The cool thing is if--when you
update or you've just pressed finished, the
cool thing is when you actually pull an update,
Eclipse will also automatically capture those
files if you hit refresh in Eclipse. Waiting
for the import to be done. You can basically
see here that it's failing and that's--there's
a reason for it because some of the files
we use aren't generated. So, one more thing
you have to do when you actually checked out
the code is to run an.gen_jxp. It's generating
the files we use for our templates. So once
that's done, you can refresh your project
in Eclipse and it should all go green. Here
we go. Only warnings; no errors. And then,
you're basically good to go. So, I told you
about the compliance as one thing that's under
projects in two settings and then Java compiler.
Make sure you have 1.6 selected here. It's
1.6 by default for me but if it's not, you
can you can edit any of your projects to specific
settings on. Make sure it's set the way the
annotations like overwrite work properly and
you don't get any compiler errors. One quick
thing which I'm--which I also want--would
like to show you is the--I opened another
project--is that you can basically run from
Eclipse if you make your own run configuration,
which serves--which uses all the arguments
the run script has. And this allows you to
run in Eclipse and debug and set break points.
And we'll go into some more deeper details
about GWT Host Mode and how to hook that up
with Eclipse during some other sessions, maybe
Installfest this afternoon, I'm not sure.
So yeah, let's switch back. So when you have
the code in Eclipse, you also have a formatting
file which we use to keep our code style,
well, equal across our code base. This--we
do this for a couple of reasons. It makes
it easier to read different clauses, especially
when you have not--you haven't been involved
in active development on those clauses but
you just happen to be able to use them for
your work. It makes it easier to review for
the reviewers if you use this style, our approach
style because while they are experienced in
this style and if you actually use it, they
don't have to spend that much time on telling
you how to fix it. Would actually--can spend
more time on whether or not your patch or
T works properly. It also makes maintenance
easier if you know--if the code is well-styled,
you can easily see--you can more easily see
where--what's going on where and what might
be going wrong. And as I said before, for
Eclipse the formatting is provided. When you
do the check out, as I've shown before, Eclipse
will automatically pick up the formatting
for you so you don't have to do anything.
The formatting is based on what we do inside
Google, which is based on the Sun formatting
with a few more changes. So, yes, about your--if
you make a patch, try to keep it small. Basically,
we would like it--I mean, for big changes,
you should actually try to write it up into
smaller changes. Each of them should still
be meaningful though, because a meaningless
commit is flawed, not very useful. Also, it
makes it easy to isolate faults if you go
step by step. It's easier for the reviewer.
There's nothing more terrible than waking
up on Monday morning and seeing that you have
a 5,000 line code review waiting for you.
We call them Eupitarian code reviews. But,
yeah, that sucks. Also, a lesson I learned
during a talk given by Ben Collins-Sussman
and Brian Fitzpatrick is that commit early
and commit often and don't be afraid to show
your work. This is actually a talk you can
find on YouTube. It's called Programmer Insecurity
and the Genius Myth. They've given this talk
all over the U.S. and all over the world,
I guess. They gave it at Google I/O 2009 as
well. Everybody feels it's relevant. Don't
be afraid to show your work. We are--the team
itself is very--pretty eager and we really
like to help you along if you run into any
problems, so, yeah. And this is maybe something
you can also take with you. You should not
be sitting in your own shell just coding away.
It's good to work in a team. Then we have--once
you have created your small commit--or your
small patch, we perform code reviews on it.
This is so we can uphold our code quality.
It makes it easier to maintain, easier to
change our code base if we actually have reviewers
reviewing your code because every line of
code is seen by multiple people. This allows
you to share the knowledge that's inside your
patch to multiple people. So if you leave,
someone else must have seen that code before.
So it allows knowledge to be distributed.
Reviewers usually check the first three items.
Does it solve the right problem? Has it been
written before? And if so, then you need to
re-factor, I guess. Is it idiomatic or whether
or not it's actually in a natural language,
is it easy to read? In some sense, they want
you--of course, they adhere to the style guide,
but you should actually just do that on your
own and we should not have to tell you to
do it because it takes time away from the
reviewer and he has a lot going on. The code
base is constantly changing, so they have
a lot of work to do. There's code review tools
up on codereview.waveprotocol.org, so when
you--when you want to submit the patch, you
use the code review script which is inside
the main folder and it will put up your code
on codereview.waveprotocol.org. We got--yes?
>> The style guide, because, you know, I [INDISTINCT]
so if I tried to make my code centered to
[INDISTINCT] things Java, but in those settings.
Did you want to release the settings you all
to use or...?
>>
DE RIJK: It's in the set--it's in the settings
file now. So when you...
>> Okay.
>> DE RIJK: ...using your--when you're creating
your projects in there, and otherwise, you
can actually import the formatted settings
into your own project.
>> Not all of the settings are in there? Like,
in generally, in Google does, like, all--the
defaults are all slightly different, so there
are some--there are some settings on that.
So, for example, my Eclipse changes all the
time that I don't have, like, serialized ID
or something that, you know, that we--the
settings file should be fixed to make the
setting ignore that one as well but more [INDISTINCT]...
>> DE RIJK: Yeah, ignoring warnings is just
maybe one of the issues. But many code style
and how the line and spacings and all that
kind of stuff is in there.
>> Right. So if users doesn't have the sense
[INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: Yup. And otherwise...
>> [INDISTINCT] format that you can...
>> DE RIJK: Otherwise, you would try to--if
you're not using Eclipse, I don't think we
have a detailed document up on it, but you
should try to mimic whatever is around your
code because that's usually supposed to be
right. So try to mimic whatever you see.
>> I already have done that with the Java
application.
>> DE RIJK: That's good. Okay. So, next stop
is that we have a continuous build and test
running. This we do to isolate breakages.
We actually broke something yesterday, so
it mailed me and I fixed it. But the...
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: Yeah, it mails to the list and
it mails, I think, the person who committed
it. I think--yeah, which is good. We do this
after a commit has been placed due to what
the tool does. You're supposed to be running
a test beforehand, so I should be ashamed,
I guess, for breaking something. But the tests
in libraries take 50 minutes and we might
work on that later on. It's running on this
link. It's hard for me to pronounce to you
all. I can actually show you, of course. It's
basically running Hudson on our two repositories.
We have seen--the weather--the weather is
kind of sunny for default. There are some
clouds for libraries because that was broken
yesterday. This tool will show whether or
not the builds are good to go. They're not
green, but they're blue here, unfortunately.
Apparently--oh, we're there. Yeah, and our
rule is basically to develop--push any changes
if broken, except when we want to fix those
changes; otherwise, it might become harder
to actually fix whatever is broken if you
keep building on broken stuff. Well, the last
thing I want to discuss is how to deal with
dependencies inside this open source project.
Open source is a wonderful thing. There is
a lot of code out there that you can use.
Basically, anything you can think of has been
written, I would say. So, yeah, in the sense,
again, don't reinvent the wheel. Wave in a
Box is licensed under Apache 2.0, which basically
means we can use Apache 2.0 projects and BST
licensed and MIT as long as we stay away from
GPLv3 which...
>> Or v2.
>> DE RIJK: Or v2 which it's not compatible
with and there are other issues with that.
We're good to go. And for new Wave dependencies,
we want to introduce is you should use a properly
release so we can find it back. Some of our
third-party code, we have some patches on
top of it because they did not--other releases
did not work well and they never made any
release sometimes. We also include a readme
file to state which version where you got
the Search--source from, what it's used for
and we also would like to try and include
source files whenever we include dependencies
because then when you're a debugger and you
can actually step through those source files
with third-party libraries and see what's
going on with your code. And that's about
it. I would like to answer any questions you
have or start discussions on how we can improve
our process or whatever you want to bring
up about how we do--how we deal with external
contributors. Thank you.
>> How many external contributors do you actually
have around?
>> DE RIJK: I think we have around four who
have access.
>> Yes.
>> DE RIJK: I'm not sure about the numbers.
I'll be--I'll be an external one soon, too,
so.
>> Just to change the question, how many people
can send in patches?
>> Yeah, by then, more than four, for sure.
>> DE RIJK: Yeah.
>> Because you don't actually have to be an
active contributor to what--to submit a patch
A to B, you know?
>> DE RIJK: No. You can just submit a patch
and someone will review it for you and can
fix it if need be, but--then that person will
commit it, but we have around--we have a few
external people who have rights to actually
push code to our code base. And if you are
an active committer and you've bit off a well-quality
code, we will give you that access.
>> Don't they--because a computer license
you have to sign but then you can submit patches.
>> Yes. It's not any project where everybody
will just enter this process. So the small--if
you're just doing it in a one point [INDISTINCT]
a year or so [INDISTINCT] deeply involved
in the process, you just [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: Yeah, there's--there's just one--yeah,
there's one license you have to--that you
totally sign...
>> Yeah.
>> DE RIJK: ...either as an individual or
if you're working for a company because in
case this code needs to be re-licensed, that
means--yeah, we have a statement from you
that that's okay. Basically, that's what it's
used for as far as I know. Anything else?
>> So, the process is fine for things you
want to introduce as the actual model. But
is there a way we can support a community
building up applications that only have very
defined uses not [INDISTINCT] but things to
say, "Hey, these are all sample datas or sample
of our plug-ins." [INDISTINCT] things people
would [INDISTINCT] Wave in a Box that might
not hit in the actual spec, but it should
be housed in one location so that, you know,
you can get it done, [INDISTINCT] it and wrapping
up demos around here so that then [INDISTINCT].
[PAUSE] They don't know what's the date and
time to build the reviews and say if you haven't
done any [INDISTINCT] here a clone of the
download and lay around if you want to [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: That's a good question. I think
we don't have...
>> It shouldn't have occurred. At a very basic
level, it shouldn't have occurred which you
can stop submitting card or patches to people
saying, "Here's an idea I've got. Here's the
patch. What do you think?" But then you can
sort of wait it down to like a gallery of
contributed gadgets or what's--that sort of
thing.
>> DE RIJK: Yeah.
>> Actually, maybe having this as an experimental
branch or an experimental folder, you know,
in the [INDISTINCT] would be useful. Basically,
you can still have the mainline Wave in a
Box, but then if there's something that isn't
directly installed in the Wave in a Box, which
I think is where you're getting at, having
an experimental folder which is a little bit
more free-formatted isn't reviewed in exactly
the same way is appropriate.
>> Yes. And another thing, it doesn't necessarily
have to adhere to the license structure to
be included in Wave. So if someone--I think
I heard is--doesn't work when we plug in,
that should be housed in order for someone
that has localized this and then we share
that [INDISTINCT], you know.
>> DE RIJK: I'm not sure we can legally put
that on our code at Google.com or we are at
[INDISTINCT].
>> Well, not at Google itself, but basically,
the plug-in that we're making [INDISTINCT]
also have your, you know, your license work
or whatever.
>> I think it's common to create a distributor
project that has the structure that overlays
on top of the core project. So you check out
the core project and then you check out the
unit project and drop the code in and then
you can build everything together. But the
particular project is named as central to
the--from the core project, so you don't have
to impose some of the more strict processes
on the contributor stuff.
>> Right. And can we do that in as simple
adaptation instead of everybody having all
this stuff somewhere [INDISTINCT].
>> I think anybody can create a "google.com
project."
>> DE RIJK: You can actually just click on
clone on the Google code webpage.
>> My point is can we support it community-wise
as opposed to...
>> So you're looking for a centralized repository
of these experimental things?
>> Yeah, sure, yeah.
>> Yeah, that will be tough.
>> I mean, because right now, some of them
post something on the Wave protocol and say,
"Oh, I've done something in there," and then
that's just lost if someone comes in the protocol
and have no idea how to find that because
there's nothing [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: It will be nice if we could include
that on the Wave protocol org website as well.
>> You said that set up a website Wave sort
of [INDISTINCT] or something like that. So
this is a set-up and even surface [INDISTINCT]
on how you set-up a protocol at Google or
anything?
>> Well, that is...
>> Yeah, I think actually what you could just
do is, like, part of your documentation things,
you could add in that says if you want to
do something that isn't directly in line,
just check into experimental/Pooh where Pooh
is the name of your research.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> DE RIJK: There's a question at the back.
>> Are there any plans today or over the next
few days to kind of go over the source code
structure, like, what folders--what's in each
folder kind of thing...?
>> DE RIJK: So...
>> [INDISTINCT] because there's like, a coder
source and of the source [INDISTINCT] all
of the folders have been [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: So the question for the people
who's still watching is whether we will go
over the--how this co-source code is structured
inside a repository. I currently don't have
an answer to that, but I think we will, but
I don't know when. I'm not sure anyone...
>> What we could do is just on top of the
install process [INDISTINCT] also at the same
time, if people wanted to sort of--I can put
Joseph on the spot and...
>> DE RIJK: Preferably on top of installer's
ware we should be able to do that and we're
here all weekend. Basically Thursday and Friday
are also our coding days and that's definitely
where we--why you would go deeper into the
code or we can help you out with that.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: Yeah. And if you have any suggestion
how to make it better, you're welcome, really.
>> We're also try to throw in a [INDISTINCT]
talk tomorrow the--you talking about authentication.
I'm talking about the Wave [INDISTINCT].
>> DE RIJK: Yeah. So I know it's in the presentation
for tomorrow include where the code is actually
located.
>> Yeah.
>> DE RIJK: So, yeah. Anything else? I guess
not. I think we are done here.
>> Yeah, so.
>> DE RIJK: Next.